his father's grave robbing hell vinkel
comes here almost once a week this time
he lets me join him in this very
personal moment a year ago his life
changed forever what happened exactly
I've been in France so I was a student
in marketing in France and yeah when I
when I left a student room I received a
call of my mom and she was saying to me
and she was crying and she said well the
father your father is dead and I I was
trite I was shocked it was a deep
connection we had contact nearly every
day especially when I when I take
decisions and I don't know what's wrong
or right I would love to know his
opinion
and this is your dad here we are yes
exactly before when you look at this
picture is what's inside you I mean I
owe a lot to him he's the person he's a
reason why this company still exists so
we all owe a lot to him but he's also
the reason why you had to change your
life no the the reason why I needed to
change my life or why I wanted to change
my life is that we've got 30 free
employees and therefore it would have
been a pity if everybody is unemployed
and I know everybody from my early youth
Robin shows me around the factory he was
suddenly in charge of at the age of only
23 it's not a high tech startup they
produce waffle irons Robin is now
responsible for everything people
budgets and strategy when is the time
where you don't have under control you
feel like I'm really young for all
what's happening a year it happened a
lot especially when I when I'm exposed
to to new situations and to new problems
if a problem is new and you haven't
solved before you're pretty much more
insecure in solving the problem
Robin has lost his father his mother is
the only one left in his family I
finally get to know Gabriella she works
at the company with her son who is
actually her boss the relationship has
grown much stronger I wonder whether
he's become a mummy's boy I always have
my ideas I always have my own willpower
and therefore maybe she would love to
have his son more and her way but I
really have my own thoughts my own
beliefs and I go my own way I feel like
he had no real choice other than
accepting his new role what expectations
on him must have been very high shirin
in a housing list by Lucas took over why
was it important that Robin has to take
over the company not someone else yeah
does this is no it's a lot of a million
visitors behind us in orange reason I
had fun kind of machinery mild unhappy
fumigate come on at kisaki are 23 yeah
yeah a current of us unlost mom about
yeah wisely avoids of you Hamish
langoria Pollock does van about lunch
item does volcanic rocks and Hiram /
today a medium crop analyst and scheana
bad meatball and she didn't OD bulb and
Shiro mad cos a quiche bath Moses Mahone
unlike Robin his friend Maxine has been
able to choose his own career path
he has a cool car he has his the boss
there has everything everything I want
but not every time I want it so would
you switch with his job oh no I don't
think so why because its first of all
it's a lot of responsibility but this is
something months someone can cope with
but the fact is being put in like it's
like being put in in 10 years but just
today and like being like put in like
yet Big Daddy's world and everything
because he's doing this job oh i think
is now may be missing the life with no
pressure or at least very few very few
pressure going very safe everything is
fine tonight Robin it's the weekend it's
time to party finally no
responsibilities
but I get the feeling that problem is
not letting loose like the others
perhaps because I'm still here with a
camera and you forget
I'm my dad
to be there every time of the day but
right now I can still be myself well we
party on since the weekend won't last
forever